on va dire malheureusement ou
heureusement même accident m'a bonifié
parce qu'avant j'étais trop limitée dans
ma façon de penser par faisait de la
moto j'avais pas notion des bestiaux pas
pour elle il pourrait y avoir que des
fractures de même de finir c'était pas
c'était un coup et là bonjour je n'aime
pas travailler excuse pour pouvoir vite
retombé à la vente aux et quand je
tombais que je savais que j'étais cassé
je pleurais pas parce que j'avais mal tu
parle parce que j'avais tout de suite
c'est avec 45 jours de plâtre
[Musique]
la semaine on accède en jetons d'efforts
en course mais j'ai une perte de
connaissance de dix minutes
en rentrant chez moi j'ai bien
d'ailleurs faut forger réécrire et ça va
mal finir
et du coup la semaine d'après j'avais
une course sur l'année passée ça s'était
très bien passé et j'avais ouvert mon
magasin à 18 ans d'enquêté des tonnes
j'ai dit bon match de bosser les
charitois qui m'a demandé d'aller river
motojima je prends la mutuelle pour
arriver et j'ai vu un son un peu un peu
probable un peu à la con et je dis bon
bah c'est l'ambiance et du coup ma
bêtise a pris le sujet avait une théorie
non c'était 3 prise d'élan
j'ai essayé une fois deux fois que la
première fois enfin vfc après le clap
heurts ont fait des bêtises c'est pas
moins du coup j'y suis allé je suis un
peu de pêche plan b à peu près de 3 4
mètres de haut la tête la première j'ai
cassé 4,5 m
je suis la salle et tu as fait un grand
score mon pote
à cette époque là c'était la volonté
qu'ils aient différence mais pour moi je
me prenais pour un super héros et je me
disais que même avec une desserte en
deçà avec force et et volonté dans tous
les cas je reviens au début j'ai
beaucoup travaillé je pensais que ça
allait revenir il bout de cinq mois je
suis tout de suite rendu compte que
c'était cramer que c'était fini le début
voilà parti va je sais pas qui la
tracasse jamais mais c'est ma toute
première moto de 50 tuerie j'ai attaqué
là dessus j'avais 4 ans c'est une
philosophie chez une limite à ouattara
son père il adore ça et ça nous met la
changement dans notre famille de tous
pouvoir en faire en famille et ça c'est
juste exceptionnel rame en mêlée ce
moment est vraiment con avec la moto
était plus magique
mon père l'a très mal vécu ça pendant un
moment pas ce produit c'est un mythe
fautive et je vais beaucoup expliqué
jeudi une notice faire si j'étais jeune
et j'ai voulu les stupides touati bruno
tu m'a donné la passion qui m'a jamais
obligé à faire ce que j'ai fait ça c'est
moi même qui décide et j'étais assez
grand pour prendre la décision toi t'as
pas t'en vouloir voir tu peux être
content parce que j'ai vécu des choses
aller retour
qui sont trop fortes
le jeu vidéo revient fort après ça parce
que des courbes un avec mon problèmes
que j'ai eus aux poudres le jour dans la
saison ça m'a beaucoup abîmé rapidement
revenir mon coude et je pouvais plus
pousser dépasser mes limites là dedans
alors que je n'ai beaucoup avec le jeu
vidéo ça m'a permis de retrouver un peu
justement ce que j'aime dans la
compétition est toujours forcer les
farces et forcé et là j'ai retrouvé mon
rang où justement je retrouve les
sensations même si ce n'était pas nous
pas le fait de sentir une progression et
d'aller travailler et à m'améliorer ça
c'est vraiment du bien moi j'étais super
content de me dire que j'allais pouvoir
avoir un domaine où j'allais pouvoir
travailler longtemps samba sow et au
début j'ai beaucoup joué sa part être
mais c était trop limité j'étais frustré
quand même des limites et ricotta et
sinon j'ai demandé à ma chérie de
regarder sans condition ce que moi je
pensais pas que ça existait on trouve
une somme sont justement pour pouvoir
jouer sur consoles ou pc
au tout début a été découverte au match
aller c'est un politique c'est ce que
j'utilise à l'heure d'aujourd'hui le
coup après j'ai retrouvé notre solution
alors à trouver des deux sticks
analogiques et logique avec ce système à
la bouche avec toutes ses fonctions à
bouche et les moutons que j'ai la
justice si j'arrivais à compiler tous à
sa lettre notre île est une machine va
on voit pas maman à marans gauche j'aime
bien ce team permet justement de placer
à ma gauche en fait je vais avoir de ski
java accueillera comme ça pas mieux
quand j'inspire s'amène à gizeh après
qu'on chauffe le mieux
je sors quand je souffre la droite ça
change d'arbres quand je souffre la
gauche ça ferait les drones et s'inspire
sol et coutras et après pour m'asseoir
malange m'allonger salaires en bas
lorsqu'il m'a pas vraiment c'est des
choses avec les gens en fait j'aime bien
changer avec les jours discuter de leur
métier de la vie de tous les jours et
montrer aussi justement c'est pas parce
qu'on est souvent quelques notre vie est
terminée
ça venait pas quand ça parce que vous
avez bien dit qu'aujourd'hui
pour faire un petit stream méga ouais ça
vient d'abattre saveljic je maintiens le
but il est là c'est pour moi il est de
montrer qu'on peut être heureux mais
qu'on peut être compétitifs mais nadal
qu'on peut attendre à à faire des trucs
quand même bien on va dire ce que
j'aimerais arriver à faire dans les
prochaines années ça serait d'arriver à
organiser des énormes nous événement
avec des roses trimer pour pouvoir
récolter pas mal de fonds pour justement
et des autres personnes en situation de
handicap à financer l'arcep table parce
que ça coûte même d un certain certains
budgets
ça sera juste énorme énorme et puis
après a réalisé juste avant mais cessons
de jouer avec ces gens là ça serait
juste d'apothéose venir